hey I'm Tiffany Haddish and I'm Kevin
Hart of right now we are doing the wires
autocomplete interview yeah
all right quiet on the set
[Music]
it's Tiffany Haddish
related to Oprah in my mind I am its
Tiffany Haddish hair real not today no
not today today this is really somebody
else here on my head yeah I got that
shocker wants it I want to play with
what I'm Tiffany she came off came back
my help but I've had a lot of really my
mother here is I have a lot yes Tiffany
has a Sigma Gamma Rama roasting Sigma
Gamma Rho no I don't even know what that
is
sorority oh no didn't didn't make it to
that foreign country is Tiffany Haddish
in maroon 5 video yes I am I'm in a
maroon 5 girl like you video is Tiffany
Haddish in a relationship with myself
and my Twitter I got off a group okay
alright
and my weighted blanket okay we have a
serious relationship
no I'm not in a relationship see Kevin
Hart dude Kevin Hart go to Temple I'm
assuming that you're talking about
Temple University in Philadelphia PA yes
I went there twice to perform yes when
did Kevin Hart become famous I became
famous when people started snapping
their fingers and trying to figure out
who I was something like you to God you
know what do I know you from that's when
I felt like I started becoming famous so
I would say after paper soldiers know
the Kevin Hart audition for SNL very
truth I didn't get it I was pretty bad
then really do characters and I tried to
pull some out of my ass and it just
didn't go the way I planned it
the Kevin Hart finished the NYC Marathon
yes I did not as fast as I wanted to I
did in like 4 hours and 2 minutes I was
on pace to do it in like 3 3340 but at
Mile 19 apparently there was a sniper on
the roof that shot me in the legs or
something called cramps they said my
last two miles took me 28 minutes that's
a truth story did Kevin Hart sell out a
football stadium
yes that's factual information in
Philadelphia PA the Lincoln Financial
Center where the Eagles play my
especially what now was taped there and
we did sell out a football stadium big
moment big deal for me
it's Tiffany Haddish dating Tyler Perry
any question no but I'm not it's tight
he's Tiffany Haddish adopted no I never
did get adopted I wish I would have got
adopted but now what adopt you but we're
the same age I take it back
is Tiffany Haddish your own lady from
the reality show
Oh Oh my god
you know audition for that show Flavor
Flav when I found out that it was Flavor
Flav you had to be in a house and I was
like oh no thank you I don't want this
job thank you is Tiffany Haddish
AirTrain yes here's my father's AirTrain
so I'm aerotrain good for you yeah okay
do you speak the speak another language
I speak another night I don't speak
amharic very well it's angering me very
well I just know how to say it come away
what is that thank you
what yackinelli yackinelli yackinelli
yackinelli yackinelli cuddly
how old is Tiffany how old is Tiffany
Haddish networks
yeah they see how old is it baby saying
I'm worth two million dollars for the
last two years so two years but that's
not how much I'm worth don't you need to
fish I was back to me with Tiffany
Haddish married to Will Smith is Kevin
Hart is Kevin Hart and all ages show
absolutely not which is very weird
because I've seen a lot of people bring
their kids to my show is if I've
somewhat given off this persona that I
have a PG stand-up comedy act I never
had make eye contact with some of these
kids I'm just yeah so no no I am NOT an
all-ages comedy show I don't let my kids
watch my show is Kevin Hart
what does I say is K Hart got in is
Kevin Hart guy Annan check them I don't
think so my eyebrows are pretty amazing
style
that's their guy in and they're not all
right
it's Kevin Hart a singer funny you ask
there was a point there was a point in
my time where I had a choice you know I
could have made a right or a left and
the right of course was music and the
left was comedy I don't know you know I
chose comedy but music chose me so I
guess it's up to you to discover all
right all right you're the great singer
okay it's Kevin Hart a rapper it's funny
you should ask
I guess it depends on what your mind
says to me my smile go to the next
question
it's Kevin Hart still alive what the yes
yeah I've been killed twice on the
internet about a way to times up yes
I've been dead twice so far on the
internet that's how you know you're
amazing but no I'm I'm here I'm talking
to you about me so I think I am very
much alive the Tiffany Haddish look like
what does it mean I look like this no
okay this if any Haddish have children
no I don't have any children
Tiffany Haddish speak Spanish I mean
mucho gusto bailout means can't unless
somebody says he loves me she loves
tacos on Tuesdays where does Symphony
Hattie's live man South Central Los
Angeles whoa whoa whoa why is getting
high everywhere because I like to be
wide it's in the heart say pineapple
that's a safe word you have a sexual
activity and they've gone too far
why does Kevin Hart have the Rose filter
I'm the only personal snapchat with the
Rose filter because it's an agreement
that I made with snapchat and I don't
want anybody else to have it and it's
something that I pull out whenever I
feel good about myself
it's not a fact I'm gonna do it as soon
as I'm done here why is Kevin Hart
what male rated-r there's a lot of
profanity and you know this there's just
a lot of profanity
hey that's our wired name if that is I
wired interview and I'm going to close
it with a rose filter right now watch
this - that thing I'm gonna show you
right now tell me no and they're gonna
hear it so they're gonna know - this -
Bruce watch this okay get ready hold on
here we go here we go and Rose is coming
there's my rose it's in here Tiffany I
don't know where is that